what is up there citizens of the reject
Nation thank you so much for joining us
on this Wednesday journey and thank you to all
who have been subscribing that means the world
subscribe and click the notification Bell do that
do that be great join the reject Nation leave a
like leave a like for Wednesday Adams and how
good this show is John how are you I'm excited
and spooky and all the things how are you good I'm
excited to reap what I woe alrighty guys also full
interaction watch alongs where you sync up with
your own copy of Wednesday available for a super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page thank you
to all who have joined our page so far and uh if
we cover several shows over there exclusively
with the reaction highlights and watch alongs
included gonna mention that every every intro you
know how we do alrighty guys well let's get to it
how well do we really know our parents
not well at all I was accused of a murder that
took place right up there which leads me to wonder
1990. hey
[Music]
foreign
's fault they were fighting over her it's
because he didn't go to the Raven with you
I love it
right that's enough Adams let's go Gomez was
definitely taller this guy stabbed himself and
then jumped I don't buy it [Music] Suave son of a
bee hmm I like him having a mysterious background
get some more Lurch in the show Catherine zeta's
got that perfect walk down but I'm happy to report
that the Eugene is on the mend and it's expected
to make a full recovery what the real Eugene
showed him to me trying to coma have you been to
see him okay so he is alive to look at my family
talk about toxic pack mentality I give my mom
30 seconds before her judgy claws come out
claws are a metaphor how are you my little Wayne
Club I thought thing was filling you in on my
every move so how's the little fella doing he's
still stealing the show since you've abandoned
me here I've been hunted haunted and the target
of an attempted murder ah Nevermore I love you so
flashing back to the Glory Days look at you
yes Gabrielle hasn't shown her face since
I started here probably sounding herself
somewhere on the seashells my darling daughter
oh I made it wouldn't miss this for the world
she looks horrified do you remember when we did
that duet your Judy Garland impression
was a Dead Ringer sounds positively
let's do it my picture's
gone really well that is odd
Wednesday's assimilation has been Rocky at
best because I refuse to embrace the culture
of dishonesty and denial permeating the school
my girl Dr kimbert and I have spoken and we both
agree it would be most beneficial for you all to
attend a family session this weekend oh wow that's
gonna be good what can I heard I mean to be honest
I've always been a big fan of hair shrinking
go see Trader Sam it's hard to stomach a murderer
wander around town scot-free at least they care
enough about Wednesday to go to therapy with her
ah tape off the scene I'll be right there you okay
what's going on you know Reggie the local coroner
he just blew what whoa why would he do that
oh you get food in therapy there maybe
we can discuss what it's like having
Wednesday away from home it's been
hard not having Wednesday around oh
I never thought I'd miss being waterboarded
so much into good time Pugsley and good time
who was Garrett Gates and why
are you accused of murdering him
whoa I know your father's an innocent man local
sheriff doesn't seem too convinced Wednesday stop
it was neither the time nor the place actually
this is exactly the place these sessions
it's not concern you you're getting defensive Tish
thanks for the candy actually that's potpourri why
don't you say something earlier yeah come on I
was wondering it's kind of weird that they were
eating in therapy How Could You Ambush your father
like that you insisted I go to this school did you
really think I wouldn't find out your secret
you don't know story your father did nothing
wrong I'll be the judge of that a good time for
a vision it sort of looked like he murdered him
how did you find me Morning Song Community
misses you they gotta find another place to
congregate the only place in town it's time to
come that place was never my home Gideon said
you'd resist don't say that man's name to me
you think he'd give a damn about some single
mom or her daughter if we weren't Sirens that
is no way to talk about your stepfather oh damn
my siren song is drying up
recruitment numbers are way down and the
wrong people are starting to ask questions
wasn't a request this is a sudden plot you got
until the end of the weekend to say your goodbyes
show some unlikely friends it was making me care
about Bianca thanks for keeping an eye on him
he didn't deserve this that should be in that
bad why did you go without me she's is getting
emotional you must be Wednesday Eugene's moms Sue
and Janet oh so excited to finally make a real
well I brought him some money Eugene loves
those dang bees like they're his kids
his fuzzy Buzzy babies oh he's gonna be okay
look how uncomfortable she is I know we got
security footage black bubble gum got them
scrubbing through video to find out how long
it's been there black bubble gum damn it he felt
guilty about an old case he says he covered it up
faked the coroner support and has been living with
that guilt for all these years it's a setup case
uh Garrett Gates you heard of him I'll wait 30
years to put away his murder what a weird timing
[Music]
oh that looks delicious we're not hungry dog my
appetite eludes me mother the same way the truth
alludes you the Niger appetite for justice
we need to tell them she'll never believe us
you'd be surprised truth will set you free it's
kind of interesting to portray the parents like
almost antagonistic Ajax and I haven't defined
our relationship yet I'm not talking about
have you walked out yet the judgmental Claw
is coming out no well that is a disappointment
it's me just wait till episode eight
no you're not gonna arrest him oh my
God you're under arrest for the murder
of Garrett Gates do the right to remain
silent anything you say Canon will be
used against you in a court of law oh this is
[__] well I got nipples from everyone too
[Music] oh buddy
how's your mother devastated she
hates you in Orange [Laughter]
is the hard color to pull off it all came
to a head the night of the Raven dance
system protects Predators he's Twisted enough
for your mother had made him insane his eyes
pour into me brimming with murderous intent go get
out of here he won't hurt me what were his powers
by jealousy and hate Gary was Unstoppable oh damn
[Music]
this dude is extremely jealous almost
seems like he's possessed of something
when I saw the sword
s it's rabid it was a terrible accident
why wouldn't Wednesday believe this
has a really good effect had really good timing
his confession sounds entirely plausible perhaps
my father is exactly what he says thank you for
being so honest with me uh perhaps not but then
there's the matter of his toes the way he smoothed
his mustache the way he delivers a comforting wink
I've been playing Russian roulette with
him since I was 12. haha who's sorry I
wasn't a better father how many fathers hand their
daughter a fencing blade when she's five years old
you say The Strokes were an essay
in Perfection we'll teach you how
to swim in sharks they found
you as cold-blooded and I do
father of the year you taught
me how to be strong and
how to navigate myself and Prejudice you
are the reason I understand how imperative
it is that I never lose sight of myself
touching so as far as fatherhood goes
I would say you've been more than adequate
wow well a Sentimental sentence Bernice may
or may not have received a call that her
tabby cat Swifty is being held for ransom
all I see is a guilty man is
finally going to pay for his crime
covered in myself oh that was the icing on
the cake such a prick I found the monsters
cave and I gave you the DNA evidence did you
even bother to test it no match inconclusive
whoever hurt Eugene also murdered
the coroner unfortunately someone
sabotaged the security camera and the
morgue so we don't know what happened
this is all a distraction no this is about Justice
being served Garrett Gates's family deserves
closure even if none of them are around to take
comfort in it his mother herself in the backyard
his father drank himself to an early grave and
even his little sister didn't Escape that was
darkest [__] ended up drowning oh every last
one of them's gone no there's a cover-up happening
here so someone knows how to cover things up
to make it look like they're often themselves
happy wolf summer camp speed up the wolf process
uh so camps for like cantherby conversion
I need to be dramatic in it you want to
send me to conversion therapy for werewolves
what wonders for your cousin Lucille didn't
it speak up Dad you forgot your fishing gear
stop trying to be nice doesn't suit you father
packed your favorite bait severed fingers
foreign [Laughter] let's
see if the fish are biting
[Laughter]
it's quite a catch God damn you have to find out
the truth and free dad well until that happens
we both know mother will be falling apart
look at that Focus damn which means we have
to be strong and by we I mean you you're
the glue now Pugsley give me one of those
I love these shots they out of the out-of-focus
backgrounds under the lake the light reflecting
on them great contrast between all the colors
and then they're monochromatic palette so you're
a Nightshade actually I rejected them
I'll never live up to your legacy here
I win the Poke up you claimed it four times
I joined the fencing team you captained it
damn the group was started by an ancestor of your
fathers from Mexico goody I saw her painting at
Pilgrim world how ironic since she was the one who
killed Joseph craigstone the night shades were her
secret but deadly answered to his oppression whole
answers father didn't kill Garrett Gates did he
you did I found your father fighting
for his life it was terrifying
[Music]
I'll never forget the way he looked at me he was
even foaming at the mouse yikes it was like I was
staring into the eyes of a rapid piece looks like
crisp and Glover that guy that's love baby [Music]
okay [Music]
my father was so calm it's a good man
true love can you believe right now go to your
room and lock the door you were never here his
voice does sound like him that's a good
match evil when they cleared him if anyone
someday this would come back and not in the
fun way there's still self-defense though
you said Garrett was filming at the mouth his eyes
didn't look human well maybe it wasn't rage at all
filming saliva dilated pupils mental confusion
what are those all textbook symptoms of
Adderall is troll how can that mean there's only
one way to find out [Music] that devilish smile oh
yes when you got your first grade taking
kid he was so happy you made me smiling
I was right well well what do
we have here guess is going to
be an Adams Family Reunion and lock up
tonight even how she puts up her hands
you get comfortable you can
post bail in the morning
it's a souvenir from our outing I borrowed it
from Garrett he died from Nightshade poisoning
Garrett was dying before you stabbed
him he would have survived the fall
oh God damn yikes interesting how history
seems to keep repeating itself he had a vial
of nitrade poison that broke in his pocket he
wasn't just trying to kill father he was going
to use the Nightshade poison to murder
the entire school now how can you prove
this that blue sheen is a Telltale sign of
nightshade poisoning but you already knew
that because back when you were Sheriff you
were in charge of the case and covered it up
who was corn oh the corner yeah why did you
instruct Dr Anwar to falsify the autopsy report
you knew the truth now if there had been a trial
both Jericho's and nevermore's reputations would
have been trashed I think the only reputation you
were worried about ruining was your own Garrett
bragging to me that his father had the sheriff in
his pocket one year later you get elected mayor
real credit to the force you could have prevented
Garrett's death if you had done your job when
I lodged my complaint about him stalking me men
like you have no idea what it feels like not to be
believed oh topical you too huh what do you want
for Gomez to be let out of prison yeah [Laughter]
I should also tell the church to the sheriff
ah let him figure it out in his own times
sometimes when I touch someone or something
you get these very violent glimpses from the
past or future our psychic ability resides on
the spectrum of who we are my Visions tend to
be positive that makes me a dove you're
a raven your Visions are more potent more
powerful like the dance Raven somebody from my
bloodline reaches off from Beyond to help us
goody goody has be careful Wednesday but
he was a witch of great strength but her
Vengeance pushed her too far and even she
couldn't save herself tell her the whole story
the most Clear Vision you've
had I don't know gorgeous
only blood deaths your daughter and my son
have become close I pity any boy who gets
caught in a Viper's gaze but he must be a
good egg he asks his mom to thank for that
what if it's the mom who is the monster
nope it's Tyler It's gotta be [Music]
perfect in the role man I'm not going if I'm
into wolf out then I'm going to do it on my
own timeline and not yours got it goddamn right
at the end of this episode proud of you kiddo
I'm hip with the kids I was
hoping he sounded more like this
I'm proud of you kiddo wait until the school year
is over how do I know you won't run away again
because she gets a spin-off I knew you didn't have
what it takes to be a murderer as much as there's
things could I see this my little death trap
all the wonderful times I had here you have your
and you're making quite the impression
like the themes of this episode
[Music]
oh thought she might do it yeah last episode
it'll be a big group hug I did win as Roan
getting murdered that night excuse me when
Rowan appeared the next morning it was you
what talent show with my mother not only did
you impersonate Judy Garland you became her
ah
is it Immaculate pause Rowan's father already
knows what happened and he fully supports my
decision not to involve the authorities oh his
telekinetic abilities were driving him mad and he
attempted to murder you twice his tragic death
allowed us to rectify this situation without
casting the school or Rowan in an unflattering
light a lot of cover-ups I did what I needed
to do to Shield the school for controversy and
protect its students from half tell that to Eugene
how are you protecting him oh God please do
not let anything terrible happen to Eugene
after it's already happened once [Music]
fire will rain oh my great shot nice reflection
fire will rain was that spelled correctly
for that uh depending not good good symmetry
four-letter words rain fire rain yeah elements
yeah they were like you know region just throws
the whole thing off that's too much letters
yeah fair enough fair enough that's one
mystery solved all right another good episode
getting another mystery out of the way one Mr
resolved and but uh what I really liked about
it because I thought the mystery of Gomez Adams
uh and the murder the murder case here would I
thought I'd get hey I thought I could resolve
later and B I thought that it would perhaps
tie more directly into the immediate plot line
sure of the mystery of who's the monster and
the cover-ups there I mean but it does still
enhance the current storylines that we're dealing
with for example like unpacking the fact that
there's so much cover up so that is a part of the
hierarchy here is that the rich remain in power
the powerful like to cover things up and it's all
about the image protection and whatnot so I think
um that ties into there but what I did appreciate
most about what this episode did with even though
they got out of the way on the fifth episode and
it doesn't exactly go to serve the main story
um it it enhanced the character development
of Wednesday like with uncovering you know her
connection with her dad like I love the scene with
him in the jail and her talk because there is that
divide where she's closer she's like a tomboyish
kind of person is that offensive now every word
I say now I'm always like yes it's Tom Bush I've
ever heard anyone say it but an offensive thing
to say to someone yeah I don't know I don't know
uh you let us know but I'm gonna fall on the side
of it's all right I'll just say the qualities
of the kind of individuals she was shaped into
who are in large part due to the type of nurturing
relationship she had with her father and yet even
though she's more like her mom in a lot of ways
at least when you kind of look on the surface
she's more adapted to the more depth to the
world around her because of her dad and so
this enhanced that relationship because so much
of why she is emotionally the way she she comes
across whether it be closed off or what she cares
about or her interests are is so much to do with
her parents and this episode does so much with
uh defining yourself and not being defined by
your family which it's not like a negative thing
it's it's something I think a lot of people deal
with especially adolescence of learning to grow
into your own and not feel like you have to just
you know uh go through with upholding whatever
it is that your parents really want for you to
do but be be who you are and so there and
it kind of did both of establishing like no
there's a lot of good things she got but she
really is her own person and they it kind of
reflects through with Enid and it shows like the
the uh generational trauma that can be inherited
through the other characters especially
going through the past so I thought I'd
at least served maybe not on the plot line
it didn't directly affect the whole thing
of like who's the monster and the murders
that are happening now it does segue into
her discovering via yearbook who uh Gwendolyn
Christie really is but it at least gave a lot
of character development that uh and to me that's
arguably more important yeah I thought it would
do a little bit more for the sheriff since
that was such a big part of his introduction
yeah it was like Jordan Adams I hate the ABS
Gomez Adams lifelong Vendetta sorry about that
in my son what are you gonna do yeah um so yeah I
I enjoy I enjoyed the episode it's not my favorite
out of the five that we've seen so far but I
still really liked it and I still thought it
moved the story forward and the character our
main character forward in really nice ways yeah
absolutely I think the the addition of a parent's
day especially at a place where you go and you
know you board a boarding school I feel like has
to be something of a a both cathartic but also
tense experience because you know anytime I feel
like a parent comes into the academic environment
there's sort of a reason to be sort of on edge and
also too everyone's at that age but yeah I liked
seeing everybody's different uh family makeup
and what they have to yeah play off of but also
what informs them as characters and even though
like the thing with Enid is is not like the most
original idea ever I appreciated just the the
characterization of everybody or Bianca's mom
just getting Yeah a different view into what
each character has to deal with and why they
might behave the way they do at school without
their parents you know because of what they're
trying to these Shadows they're trying to escape
or the paradigms that they're trying to break free
of that they feel like are being forced upon them
for one reason or another and I think that they've
done a nice job of of painting a good array
it seems like you know Bianca's mother is in
you know something uh more of uh maybe not like
nefarious but something more of a uh you know
it seems like she may be up to more overt no good
than just being overbearing doubt it like uh you
know like Enid's parents or something like that
but even getting to see uh Eugene's family uh
briefly for a moment and kind of getting a clue as
to how and why he is so sweet amid this you know
array of other more prickly outcasts and whatnot
and and yeah having The Adams Family here for an
episode was also just a nice it was smart because
it's it's a tension Adder for everyone in general
but it also gets you some time with The full-on
Adams Family which like I loved getting a little
bit of bonding between Wednesday and Pugsley and
I I found actually the MGM has uh at least like
a season's worth there's like 15 episodes worth of
just old Adams Family episodes just on YouTube for
anyone to watch and and part of the like looking
back at those episodes part of the charm is
like oh yeah like Wednesday and Pugsley are often
Palling around and you know getting into Mischief
together and even though this is playing more of
a you know more of a dramatic angle on that their
relationship is strained I still found it very
charming and and the actor who plays Pugsley for
the brief amount of time we've seen him I thought
it was very Charming to get the two of them
together to get one-on-one moments with everybody
but also to get you know like the awkward family
therapy scene and stuff like that and then the
interrogation or not the interrogation but you
know like in the the jailhouse with uh Gomez in
Wednesday and sort of seeing those moments where
like I thought they gave a nice array of moments
in this episode to confront yeah the family trauma
but also to touch on the love that does exist
there and I think Jenna Ortega continues to really
excel at showing the love that exists on beneath
the surface even though she is very very averse
to expressing it and uh and yeah I love characters
like that who you can tell something means I love
you when it sounds and looks like anything but
that and you know that's bread and butter of The
Addams Family um and yeah just Louise Guzman and
uh Catherine Zayden Jones I really enjoyed across
this episode and and the the matches in the past
both in the casting and just the way they played
all that stuff through the flashback I thought
was really gripping uh yeah yeah like I don't
know if I would mark it as my favorite episode
either but it does feel like it it's one I would
remember out of the series as being you know the
the fun Adams Family only episode and I appreciate
that we got that too yeah I feel like it's sort
of uh it easily could have felt perfunctory like
we need to do an Adams Family episode and we you
know because sometimes you can feel forced and it
it didn't feel forced this is a storyline
they had to deal with and again enhancing
the characters and on top of that too it does good
World building you know it's setting up the stakes
between it's almost like an X-Men type of deal
yeah or if Muggles in The Wizarding World hated
Wizards you know yeah like if hogsmeade was the
round the corner from like a regular human town
and they had to kind of and and the way that they
touch on that like there's so many reasons to be
like ah you Jericho bastards are always conniving
against us but it's really like I did think that
as much as the the mayor is not a stand-up guy
that idea of like I was trying to protect the
well-being of Nevermore Engine America because
they're both gonna fall into this trap yeah yeah
I think they did a good job there I I think my
and I wonder how it would feel because I know most
people binge this show and this is really kind of
a slight because I really did enjoy this episode
overall I I liked it quite a bit uh for all the
reasons I said and I wouldn't want it to not be
here I did feel that there was something about the
way the pacing was from the first to the fourth
episode that kind of felt like it was ramping
up it was it was like really ramping up and
and uh it was just so it was flowing
so well and this kind of felt like
I don't want to say an interruption but it did
kind of mess with the pacing a little bit it
was definitely on the slower side and granted
I know some stuff that we might say might that
might sound like a contradiction because I'm like
yeah I love the pacing I like when it breathes and
while I do like that I guess I guess in the world
of Wednesday atoms of what of the show Wednesday
I'm not as particularly drawn to the actual Adams
Family characters as I am the other cast members
that we've been hanging out with and that might
be just like it might just be on me and I imagine
that is not a common consensus and a common
opinion it's like I enjoy them and I really
like watching them uh but I think because it's
like the fifth episode we're now like taking a
detour to focus solely on them it made me you
know I found myself like oh but I've been so
into everyone else's storyline that I've kind
of just that's where my heart's been at I bet
you that means you're halfway on that because like
for me as a viewer it's exciting and fun like I I
appreciate this as The Addams Family episode but
in being so it does feel more like an interlude
in the middle of the season with a side mystery
versus yeah the overarching feeling like it really
fully kept the overarching momentum of the show
going yeah and I I liked Gwendolyn Christie for
the BR we don't really get much of her when you
think about it we don't really get a lot of her
which I think that kind of performance too
is something that could also be it I don't
I don't know how much credit she really gets for
a performance here maybe she shines a lot more in
the later episodes because I I feel like whenever
she's there she brings a lot even in like the most
sometimes in just like the reactions she gives
and the way her and Jenna Ortega play off of
each other is really well executed and I love
the the sense of history that she carries with
her in almost every moment that she's on screen
yeah I think that resonates really strong so
I really love like I loved like the last few
minutes of this when she does piece together
and that's more of like the mystery solving that
I want to see more of like I know they had like
a minor complaint about the end of episode two
of wanting to like kind of be there with her and
I think like oh yeah that's a good that's a good
way to uh for her to figure it out yeah to put one
and one together I thought that was a good mystery
solving um for what was his name Rowan Rowan yeah
yeah with what happened with Rowan and it's well
motivated in the dialogue to the point where by
the end of the episode it doesn't feel like just a
random occurrence or a random like contrivance of
the plot or something and I agree like Gwendolyn
Christy she she's really good at always seeming
so High Str like so put together but also so high
strung that like everything is like just beneath
the surface ready to break through and she has to
kind of keep this Poise and I I think there's uh
yeah a lot of magic to what she does like whenever
she's on screen and even the actors that got to
play the younger version of her like even though
it was a recast and and whatever I noticed it but
at the same time in the moment I was like oh great
like this still feels like the same character I
do wish I really do if there's one part of
this that I I do wish we we definitely got
it that we could have received as an audience is
a better scene after Gomez is let out and between
him and the sheriff because that sheriff has been
that's been on this guy's mind for 30 years part
of his life and I felt like that scene just didn't
quite I like I like the latter half of it about
talking about like hey maybe the essentially
implying like maybe our futures can be a little
bit different because look at our children bonding
with each other right like I I get that because
the show deals so much with I mean the town itself
is so much of a history a generational trauma
situation you're dealing with and it's like trying
to keep the peace between people with powers and
normies and I did think like there there could
have just been a little bit more meat on that one
scene oh totally when after all that because
it was just kind of like but but I will say
that there is of one part of my brain that goes
well they've done a lot to also establish that the
sheriff is not exactly the most emotional guy
so he might just be the kind of Interest like
whoopsie you know and I'm like I I'm not really
gonna talk about it but he's just be like sorry
about that you know I think you could still make
a scene with that yeah learn something I I don't
know what he would have learned but uh but at
least at least more of a moment I think yeah
yeah yeah at least more of an acknowledgment of of
hey I was wrong I'm sorry for holding this grudge
against you for so many years and going out of my
way to try and apprehend you in the process yeah
yeah that was a that was one part of the that's
one part of this and I was like oh I did I did
feel like I needed that yeah and acknowledge
I mean and it would give you an opportunity to
acknowledge the way he's treated Wednesday up till
this point too but yeah and I and I don't know
what the original uh Gomez I'm not familiar with
like the original what is it comic literature what
was newspapers what New York or comic strip or
something like that I'm not familiar with what the
um OG uh representation is I don't mean that
in ethnic wise uh a depiction of Gomez Adams
is like but you know from knowing like Raul Julia
and generally how Gomez Adams is is portrayed it
is nice to get a more like subtle Gomez atoms
sure I do like what he actually brings to the
table and uh I do enjoy Catherine Zeta Jones
and they do have they don't have like electric
chemistry but they do have a nice chemistry
with each other they're not quite Rel Julia
and Angelica Houston in that department but they
yeah but I I enjoy them sketchy sometimes yeah
yeah sure that's a good way to put that I like
them very much individually and I'm happy for
the moment but even even something about the
way they realize because like him kissing all
up and down her arms is kind of a Trope of the
outer family and I feel like even the way they
handled that was like one of the more slightly
less natural things that the episode tried to do
um so I mean yes it's not it's not like a big
deal that I'd hold against it but that's what
makes me as a viewer go like oh wow I want to
get more time with them so I could feel like
Morticia and Gomez have I don't know I just feel
like the more time you spend on screen the more
they get to play the more you know that Dynamic
and that Rapport will develop and feel as time
is it's I almost bought their relationship more
as the flashback characters yeah and that might
have been too because of such a high stakes
situation there's so much emotion to bring out
of of a scene like that you know so whereas
there's there's is always sort of that like
spooky ghoulish undertone with them and it's it is
fun and I like their yeah I like their individual
scenes a lot and I I I I love the way this show
is shot I really love the cinematography like
the the reflective lighting that they always
do and there's some great like blending with
I notice it a lot with hair and background they
do an excellent job with color schemes and I I'm
so impressed to it's good to get a show where
like they put more effort into this than like a
Marvel movie I know part of me wants to look at
that like the scope of in wanting to praise the
visuals like oh well I'd love to take a look at
this side by side with some other Netflix stuff
because that's a common complaint about stuff
like Marvel but also even like Netflix shows or
streaming shows in general is like things are shot
with this sort of flat array of colors so you can
kind of do anything but I feel in post but here it
always feels like the vibrancy and the contrast of
the colors is really on point and Vivid um so yeah
I would I would definitely agree with that yeah it
pops I love I just love the aura of everything all
around so yeah I still really enjoy this episode
a lot and and I had a little bit more desire I
guess for some stuff I wouldn't really call it
like criticism I have more desire for some things
to feel a little bit more for but I I don't want
that to I really wouldn't want that to read as got
issues yeah yeah it's it's it's it's that thing
of like it's not necessarily missing something
there's just stuff I would have liked more of yeah
let's go away put it alrighty guys what did
you think about The Adams Family and Bianca
that sounds like spin-off oh there's no how
can you do that in in three in the next three
episodes are there set up for season two or a
spin-off right Wednesday and Bianca are gonna
go to the the whatever the siren place is called
and they're gonna buddy cop team up and uh and
figure out what's going on there you know I I've
I sometimes read the top comments on the I get
afraid to go to scroll through comments on these
videos I apprecially the comment uh again I'll
I'll look through them after we're done filming
uh all them I get afraid to go too deep because
whenever we're binging a show I'm like don't go
too deep because you can spell some [__] so
um I only read the top comments sometimes
they're the ones you see hearted and uh
and and I have noticed some top comments have
pointed out that General Ortega didn't want to
um like insisted that there's not a love triangle
here and that they they wanted to honor that
request or something that Echoes something like
that but I feel like the show does do it like like
we keep being reminded of it but I'm like we're
five episodes in it and it seems to point to to it
and like a romance it absolutely does and I think
it works really well and I bet it'll I I could
absolutely 100 see it coming out in the end where
she was just like yeah I just like both of you as
friends and that's it you know I'm not really
interested in this and I feel like that could
be the twist of that aspect of the story because I
think they certainly want it to read that way yeah
yeah yeah even the way of how Gomez talks about
with the sheriff about I'd be worried about anyone
that my daughter sets her deadly Viper eyes on
or some [__] yeah yeah that that would be that
that's that's definitely part of that I don't
know it's not a really big deal to me but it's
interesting to note though yeah and because
it seems like Jenna Ortega does have a fair
amount of input at least control over this thing
Dwayne Johnson she is now yes the Ryan Reynolds
of being Wednesday Adams yeah choreographed my
dance I rewrite my lines I don't want this for
the character I'm 20 years old season two written
directed produced and started uh she does seem to
have it or it just sounds like they they respect
creative contribution as the best idea wins it
might be the sentiment around the set of Wednesday
uh because that's what it sounds like she seems
like so much credit goes to her like uh her ideas
and her request and I think that's that's really
cool it's almost unheard of I know for that to
be such a conversation surrounding a show too
like it seems like a a thing I've heard just
people out there talking about you know it's
a common sentiment so it's cool to see that
uh see see such a good show come out of it
alrighty guys well what did you think about
this episode leave your thoughts down below
you can subscribe leave a like leave a like last
but not least we always end this with a patreon
Tyler Hague if I was Morticia you would
be my Gomez yeah and I would just want
to kiss you up and down from head to toe
all day every day and never stop showing
my affection for you because in some ways
you are like the Gomez Adam this Gomez Adam
there's somebody you are like the Gomez atoms
of our patreon pages always loving and super
adorable enthusiastic I don't get the impression
that you're tall you seem like a shorter fella
you know you could be like I've seen you from
here to here so I'm not really sure but you
you have a three feet tall child like teddy bear
sincerity about you and I adored that and I'll
never ever forget so much of the energy of yours
that you have shared with us throughout the years
and I look forward to just keep talking with
you buddy and whenever we make our trip out to
Wisconsin which will be in like 20 years I'm
taking a road trip because I don't think I'm
ever gonna fly to Wisconsin what's out there
if you're around in L.A let me know I'll buy
you a drink buddy yeah and let us know what's
in Wisconsin might be something worth checking
out maybe I'm a shopping mall sure a Green Bay
Packers game and red letter media we could go
visit redlander media there you go they just let
you visit yeah you could just walk in that's how
Macaulay Culkin gets there sure they love reaction
channels they love exactly what we do here and
they find Great Value in it they adore it but we
value and adore you Tyler thank you Tyler [Music]